good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
but I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the world's major problems
so to help you on your journey today our
message is bet on your strengths over to
you Gary Vaynerchuk you need to bet on
your strengths and don't give a [ __ ]
about where you suck at you're going to
way too many people in this room we're
going to spend the next 30 40 years of
their lives trying to check the boxes
other things that they're not as good at
and that you're going to waste a lot of
time and use I highly recommend auditing
yourself or if you have no empathy or EQ
or self-awareness then find somebody in
your family or friendship that does and
let them tell you who you are and once
you believe that either for yourself or
someone else told you go directly all
ships all into that because that is the
only possible way in my opinion watching
from the outside that is limited phrase
that is a very highly likely way of
over-indexing because the truth is if
you want to be an anomaly you've got to
act like one you know like and so that's
it that's what I got so thanks for
having me so this great story that I've
told before but I love it so I want to
tell it again I bought this rabbit who
goes to animal school and as he's going
to animal school he learns all the
skills that they need to learn to be a
successful animal when he grows up
and at the end of the first year he gets
his report card and on that report card
he scores an A+ in hopping and he's
scored an F in swimming and so his
parents come home and they look at the
report card and they start shaming him
to say look at how are you failing and
swimming your disgrace to the family you
got to get trained we're going to hire
you
coaches and extra practice after school
and we're going to make sure that you do
really well on swimming you're really
good at hopping so don't worry about
that just focus on the swimming and so
for the next year he's focused and
focused on focus on swimming and getting
better and better and better at it and
in the process you forgot how to hop and
that's what the swimming have you ever
seen a bunny that's when
and so this is the mindset that I think
a lot of people fall into where we get
our report cards from school or from
life and we feel that we're weak in
certain areas and our default solution
for some reason is we need to work on
fixing those weaknesses we want to be a
well-rounded individual and what ends up
happening is you become mediocre and
everything and those things that you
potentially can be world-class genius
level talent at you don't do that's not
how you have success as an entrepreneur
if you try to do everything and you only
spend 5% of your time doing the thing
that you could be great at you're always
going to be mediocre you're never going
to get the results that you want success
in business will come from you focusing
on what you can be amazing at
world-class at and spending as much time
doing that as possible and the rest you
eliminate you automate or you delegate
and as quickly as possible you want to
figure out how can I build a team around
me to complement my weaknesses so I can
go all in and what I'm great at if I
look at my youtube channel at the
starting and everything and I'm a big
believer in doing everything to get
things rolling I hate spending money
telling making money but the first group
that I made was to hire an editor for my
channel because I wasn't great at
editing I had no interest in it it was
not something that I ever wanted to be
world-class level at and getting that
editor allowed me to go from one video a
week to one video day seven times my
output by hiring that one person it
allowed me to spend more time on what I
was great at and wanted to improve that
and so when you see people complaining
about their weaknesses I would encourage
you to think and explain to them don't
worry about it what are you good at and
spend as much time there as possible
when you're doing a self-analysis look
at what do you have the ability to be
world-class Michael Jordan level talent
at and then how do you spend 80% of your
day every day doing that work so the
question today today is I'm curious what
is your greatest strength you down the
comments below super curious to find out
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Yahoo Foreman thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
and I'll see you guys again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
[Music]
you need to know what your unique
strengths are and be willing to delegate
so I would say that the question of
whether you should take a skill learn it
yourself delegated someone else or hire
new team member are determined by having
a very accurate self assessment and
assessment number your team skills not
only what you can do but what you should
be doing that's very important so if
you're a startup CEO or founder and you
have a team of say two to ten people as
soon as you have funds to hire you
should not be focused on the things that
you are bad at sounds very very
intuitive but it's not because you might
have enough time to do those things but
the question is do you have the
attention to dedicate to those things
that are not an interruption
especially if you're a venture back to
startup and you're competing as other
companies that also have a lot of
funding the game the game and the race
goes to the Swift so you have to have
you have to have a lot of velocity you
talk about managing your strengths I
know one of my weak points in my
personal life is I don't like technical
stuff so even though I have to be on
Twitter and Instagram and Facebook I
don't care for that so guess what I find
somebody who loves to do that you know I
find somebody who has a strengths where
I will have a weakness and I partner
with them all you're trying to do is get
to the goal
no one gets there by themselves
everybody needs help now when you know
what you got going for you be confident
not cocky managing your strengths
knowing what they are and don't let
nobody talk you out of it and that gets
you fight ready
you get fight ready like that you've got
to know you helps you develop your
skills a girl boss I grew up with
someone who I guess takes charge of like
her own life so it's the girl boss or
guy boss someone who knows their
weaknesses and knows what their
strengths are knows how to play to their
strengths I think there's a lot of
people out there and I've interviewed a
lot of them who my favorite interview
question is
name your biggest strength and your
biggest weakness or what you have to
work on and the scariest people the ones
who say like I show up early it's my
biggest weakness or like I work too much
my biggest weakness and you know
everybody has things that they can
improve upon and I think a world where
everybody is more aware of that is a
good one in a place where people can be
empowered to make choices in their life
rather than throw themselves into places
that they may not inherently be
successful because the world has sold
them some story of what they should be
doing so I guess the girl boss is
someone who is in choice